[Music]
dove audio presents
senza's the art of war
adapted by stefan rudnicki
read by ron silver and bd wong
with stefan rudnicki and shauna zurbruck
[Music]
approximately 2500 years ago
in a time of political turbulence and
great military activity
sunzo
a philosopher general of ancient china
assembled his observations on warfare
into 13 chapters
creating the classic work known as the
art of war
this was a long time ago and times have
surely changed yet this book of the 13
chapters has not only survived it has
exerted an extraordinary influence on
the modern world
perhaps particularly in the last 10
years or so
people of all persuasions from all walks
of life buyers and sellers soldiers and
brokers
backers and hackers in laws and outlaws
all have found inspiration and sound
practical guidance here
the period with which sims is usually
linked
roughly the mid-fourth to the mid-fifth
century before the common era
was a high point in the evolution of
human wisdom and achievement
among sons's near contemporaries were
lao tzu
confucius
zoroaster
pythagoras and pindar
heraclitus and herodotus
escalus sophocles and nisop
the prophets ezekiel and jeremiah
and
pericles of athens
religion
philosophy
music art science and literature
flourished
so did war
and conquest
there were fortifications and
conflagrations occupations and
liberations coronations and usurpations
pharaohs kings and tyrants rose and fell
empires were lost and won
for nearly 50 years the romans fought
the etruscans and the persians fought
the greeks
in china feudal states were almost
constant war dynasties rose and fell
with cruel regularity in such a time a
fine balance had to be maintained
between the traditional peaceful civic
virtues upon which chinese culture had
been built and other more militaristic
principles
even confucius
circa
551-478 bce who was probably a
contemporary of sunset and who was known
for his advocacy of peace was quoted as
saying
if i fight
i
the
win
sumatian
a principal biographer of sunzer writing
route 100 bce said
when the duke of joe was minister under
chang wang he regulated ceremonies and
made music and venerated the arts of
scholarship and learning
yet when the barbarians of the river why
revolted
he sallied forth and chastised them
when confucius held office under the
duke of lou he said
if peaceful negotiations are in progress
warlike preparation should have been
made beforehand
sumachan also stated that
military weapons are the means used by
the sage to punish violence and cruelty
to give peace to troubled times
to remove difficulties and dangers
and to aid those who are in peril
every animal with blood in its veins and
horns on its head
will fight when it is attacked
how much more will man
who carries in his breast the faculties
of love and hatred
joy and anger
when he is pleased
a feeling of affection springs up within
him when angry his poisoned sting is
brought into play
that is the natural law which governs
his being
sumatian also said of susa that he was a
native of the chi state he told this
story about the art of war being brought
to the attention of hulu the reigning
king of wu from 514 to 496 bce
houlu said to sunse
i have carefully perused your thirteen
chapters
may i submit your theory of managing
soldiers to a little test
sunser replied
you may
holu asked may the test be applied to
women
the answer was again in the affirmative
so arrangements were made to bring 180
ladies out of the palace
tsuntsu divided them into two companies
and placed one of the king's favorite
concubines at the head of each he then
made them all take spears in their hands
and address them in this manner
i presume you know the difference
between front and back
right hand and left hand
the girls replied
yes
tsun tsu went on
when i say eyes front you must look
straight ahead
when i say left turn you must face
toward your left hand
when i say right turn you must face
toward your right hand
when i say about turn you must face
right around toward the back
again the girls ascended
the words of command having been thus
explained he set up pikes and battle
axes in order to begin the drill then to
the sound of drums he gave the order
right turn
but the girls only burst out laughing
sunset said
if words of command are not clear and
distinct if orders are not thoroughly
understood
then the general is to blame so he
started drilling them again and this
time gave the order left turn
where upon the girls once more burst
into fits of laughter
said
if words of command are not clear and
distinct if orders are not thoroughly
understood the general is to blame
but if his orders are clear and the
soldiers nevertheless disobey
then it is the fault of their
officers saying
he ordered the leaders of the two
companies to be beheaded
now the king of wu was watching the
scene from the top of a raised pavilion
and when he saw that his favorite
concubines were about to be executed
he was greatly alarmed and hurriedly
sent down the following message
we are now quite satisfied as to our
general's ability to handle troops
if we are bereft of these two concubines
our meat and drink will lose their
savior it is our wish that they shall
not be beheaded
suzu replied
having once received his majesty's
commission to be general of his forces
there are certain commands of his
majesty which acting in that capacity i
am unable to accept
accordingly he had the two leaders
beheaded
and straightway installed the pair next
in order as leaders in their place
when this had been done the drum was
sounded for the drill once more and this
time the girls went through all the
motions turning to the right or to the
left marching ahead or wheeling back
kneeling or standing with perfect
accuracy and precision not venturing to
utter a sound
then sunset sent a messenger to the king
saying your soldiers sire are now
properly drilled and disciplined and
ready for your majesty's inspection
they can be put to any use that their
sovereign may desire
bid them go through fire and water and
they will not disobey
but the king replied
let our generals cease drilling and
return to camp
as for us we have no wish to come down
and inspect the troops
thereupon suzu said
the king is only fond of words and
cannot translate them into deeds
after that
holu saw that sunser was one who knew
how to handle an army
and appointed in general
in the west
suzu defeated the chew state and forced
his way into yin the capital
to the north he put fear into the states
of qi and jinn and spread his fame
abroad amongst the feudal princes
and soon so shared in the might
of the king
although the story is apocryphal and
sons's dates around 540 to perhaps 464
bce
as well as his authorship of the art of
war are in dispute
the events here described echo the tone
of the book
the expendability of individual life in
the interest of discipline and absolute
authority seems
unnecessarily cruel
and many modern translators and
commentators are quick to suggest that
these elements were meant to be tempered
by more humane confusion or taoist
principles
the fact remains however that the 13
chapters
are about war
this is not a book of general philosophy
but rather a professional manual
it was meant to be available only to a
select few a kind of
secret society of generals and kings and
not to the public at large
the book's influence spread slowly to
japan during the 8th century of the
common era and from there throughout
asia and into russia where it formed the
basis of military thought for centuries
it was completely unknown in the west
until 1772
when j.j.m amio a jesuit missionary to
pay king
published his interpretation of the art
of war in paris
amio's work was well received and widely
circulated and was published again in an
anthology in 1782
legend has it that napoleon read sunze
and this may have been the addition
the first english translation by captain
e f calthrop rfa did not appear until
1905 and the lionel giles translation
from which this version is mostly
derived five years later in 1910
for the most part the commentaries that
follow each chapter of sons's text in
this edition
are from a variety of chinese sources
several of those cited are considered
soon's
commentators
among the most prominent are the third
century general and military genius
the 8th century tactician lee chuan
do you whose commentaries were culled
from his monumental encyclopedic
treatise on the chinese constitution
and the poets
dumou
and mae yao chen
their commentaries are augmented by
quotes from other chinese writers and a
handful of more modern western
personalities including the 17th century
french military leader marshall turen
and american generals stonewall jackson
and colin powell
it is popular today to think of the art
of war as a practical guidebook for any
number of activities that require
strategy
from sports and normal business affairs
to
affairs of the heart
and it can be just that provided that
you are willing to see the world in
which you live and work as a network of
actual and potential combat zones
where the stakes are high
and struggle is the primary mode of
being where
no one is to be trusted and survival
depends on unconditional victory
war then
becomes not merely a metaphor for the
conflicts of everyday life but a state
of mind
like the oriental martial arts the art
of war emphasizes adaptability and flow
grounding the work firmly and those
elements of the chinese tradition of
subtle universal order
known to us through the yejin the book
of changes
and texts like laozi's daodejin
the very first constant factor discussed
in chapter 1 is the dao
this is most often translated as moral
influence or the moral law
as the right way
or simply the way
it is the cosmic cycle of energy
rotation and transformation the flow of
all things natural
it is the dynamic that informs the path
of least resistance
i have called it the force
as much for its appropriateness in a
military context as for its popular
sense thanks to george lucas of a
natural universal energy with which one
seeks alignment
the first move is always the opponents
telling us everything we need to know
about his strengths and weaknesses
for our part we must be sensitive to all
the conditions and circumstances that
apply including
terrain climate
cycles of season and time
personality and politics
at the same time we must give away as
little as possible about ourselves
all action needs therefore to be built
upon the shifting sands of deceit and
deliberate obfuscation
our motives and intentions hidden even
from our own side
in this
sunzel laid the groundwork for all
future espionage systems
sons of places great emphasis on the
importance of detail
and illustrations abound in statistical
terms that seem of little use to us
today after all the costs of waging war
have certainly changed
chariots armor cooking pots and other
ancient implements are no longer the
measures they once were cost and gain
however are still key issues
and these details provide us with a keen
sense of proportion
always of vital importance to the
chinese
perhaps most important to remember are
one commentator's suggestion that
warlike precepts are not to be applied
in peace time
and sums own insistence that
the best way of waging war is not to
fight at all
this second is not a pacifist statement
but simply a truth about the costs of
war
it is then
the readers or listeners moral
prerogative to decide whether
circumstances warrant engaging in war
whether there is indeed an enemy
whether the cost of the battle will be
worth the prize
and whether we are willing to risk
all
to achieve victory
[Music]
to hear the answer we must listen both
within ourselves and without to the
thousands of signals the natural world
provides
we must listen to the tao
we must attend the force
laozi said
for heaven and earth
undefined
yet complete
formless
standing alone unchanging
reaching everywhere
it is the mother of all things
i do not know its name
i call it the force
upon further reflection
i name it
the great
because it is great it is in constant
flow
passing on it becomes distant
then
it returns
therefore
the force is great
heaven is great
earth is great
the king is also great
there are four great powers in the
universe
the king
is one of them
man takes his law from the earth
earth takes its law from heaven
heaven takes its law from the force
the law of the force
is to be what it is
chapter one
laying plans
an introduction to the five constant
factors
the seven considerations
deception
and calculation
census said
the art of war is of vital importance to
the state
it is a matter of life and death
a road either to safety
or to ruin hence
it is a subject for study
that can on no account be neglected
the art of war is governed by five
constant factors all of which need to be
considered
these are
the force
heaven
earth
the commander
and discipline
the force
causes the people to be in complete
accord with their ruler
so that they will follow him regardless
of their lives undismayed by any danger
heaven signifies night and day
cold and heat
seasons
and cycles of the moon
earth comprises distances great and
small
danger and security
open ground and narrow passes
the chances of life and death
the commander
stands for the virtues of wisdom
sincerity
benevolence
courage
and strictness
discipline is to be understood as the
marshalling of the army in its proper
subdivisions
the gradations of rank among the offices
the maintenance of roads by which
supplies may reach the army
and the control of military expenditure
these five factors should be familiar to
every general
he who knows them
will be victorious
he who knows them not
will fail
therefore
when seeking to determine the military
conditions
make your decisions on the basis of
comparison
utilizing the seven considerations
in this wise
one
which of the two sovereigns is imbued
with the force
two
which of the two generals has the most
ability
three
with whom lie the advantages derived
from heaven and earth
four
on which side is discipline most
rigorously enforced
five
which army
is the stronger
six
on which side are officers and men more
highly trained
seven
in which army
is there the greater constancy
both in reward and in punishment
by means of these seven considerations
i can forecast victory
or defeat
the general who hearkens to my counsel
and acts upon it will conquer
let such a one be retained in command
the general who harkens not to my
counsel
nor acts upon it will suffer defeat
let such a one
be dismissed
while heeding the prophet of my counsel
avail yourself also of any helpful
circumstances over and beyond the
ordinary rules
plans should be modified to reflect
favorable
or unfavorable circumstances
all warfare is based on deception
hence
when able to attack
we must seem unable
when using our forces
we must seem inactive
when we are near
we must make the enemy believe we are
far away when far away
we must make him believe we are near
hold out baits to entice the enemy
feign disorder
and crush him
if he's secure at all points
be prepared for him
if he is superior in strength
evade him
if your opponent is quick to anger
seek to irritate him
pretend to be weak that he may grow
arrogant
if he is taking his ease
give him no rest
if his forces are united
separate them
attack him where he is unprepared
appear where you are not expected
these military devices lead to victory
and they must not be divulged beforehand
the general who wins a battle makes many
calculations in his temple
before the battle is fought
the general who loses a battle makes
only a few calculations beforehand
thus do many calculations lead to
victory
and few calculations
to defeat
how much more no calculation at all
it is my attention to this point
that i can foresee who is likely to win
or lose
so
south sal said this about discipline
when you lay down a law
see that it is not disobeyed
if it is disobeyed
the offender must be put to death
dumou told this story
there was a general tsao tsao
who was such a strict disciplinarian
that once
in accordance with his own severe
regulations against injury to standing
crops
he condemned himself to death for having
allowed his horse to shy into a field of
corn
however in lieu of losing his head
he was persuaded to satisfy his sense of
justice
by cutting off his hair
jung-yu said of planning
while the main laws of strategy can be
stated clearly enough for the benefit of
all
you must be guided by the actions of the
enemy in attempting to secure a
favorable position in actual
[Music]
warfare sir w fraser tells this story on
the eve of the battle of waterloo lord
uxbridge commanding the cavalry went to
the duke of wellington in order to learn
what his plans and calculations were for
the moral because as he explained
he might suddenly find himself commander
in chief and would be unable to frame
new plans in a critical moment
the duke listened quietly and then said
who will attack the first tomorrow i or
bonaparte
bonaparte replied lord oxbridge
well continued the duke
bonaparte has not given me any idea of
his projects
and as my plans will depend upon his how
can you expect me to tell you what mine
are
[Music]
chapter 2
waging war
the economics of war
and the importance of speed
said
in the operations of war where there are
in the field a thousand swift chariots a
thousand heavy chariots and a hundred
thousand male clad soldiers with
provisions enough to carry them a
thousandly the expenditure at home and
at the front including entertainment of
guests small items such as glue and
paint and some spent on chariots and
armor will reach the total of a thousand
ounces of silver per day
such as the cost of raising an army of a
hundred thousand men
when you engage in actual fighting if
victory is long and coming the men's
weapons will grow dull and their ardor
will dampen
if you lay siege to a town you will
exhaust your strength
if the campaign is protracted the
resources of the state will not be equal
to the strain
when your weapons are dulled your ardor
dampened your strength exhausted and
your treasure spent
other chieftains will spring up to take
advantage of your extremity
then no man however wise will be able to
avert the inevitable consequences
thus
though we have heard of stupid haste in
war
cleverness has never been seen
associated with long delays
there is no instance of a country having
benefited from prolonged warfare
only one who knows the disastrous
effects of a long war can realize the
supreme importance of speed in bringing
it to a close
the skillful leader does not raise a
second levy
neither are his supply wagons loaded
more than twice
once war is declared he will not waste
precious time in waiting for
reinforcements nor will he turn his army
back for fresh supplies he will cross
the enemy's frontier with no delay
bring more material with you from home
but forage on the enemy
in this way the army will have food
enough for its needs
poverty of the statex checker causes an
army to be maintained by contributions
from a distance
contributing to maintain an army at a
distance causes the people to be
impoverished
on the other hand the proximity of an
army causes prices to go up and high
prices cause the people's substance to
be drained away
when their substance is drained away
they will be afflicted by heavy
exactions
with this loss of substance and
exhaustion of strength the homes of the
people will be stripped bare and
three-tenths of their incomes will be
dissipated while government expenses for
broken chariots worn out horses
breastplates and helmets bows and arrows
spears and shields protective mantlets
draft oxen and heavy wagons will amount
to four tenths of its total revenue
hence a wise general makes a point of
foraging on the enemy
one cart load of the enemy's provisions
is equivalent to twenty of one's own
and likewise a single pound of his
provisions is equivalent to twenty from
one's own store
now in order to kill the enemy our men
must be roused to anger
that there may be advantage from
defeating the enemy they must have their
rewards
therefore in chariot fighting when ten
or more chariots have been taken
those should be rewarded who took the
first
our own flags should be substituted for
those of the enemy and the chariots
mingled and used in conjunction with
ours the captured soldiers should be
kindly treated and kept
this is called using the conquered foe
to augment one's own strength
in war then
let your objective be victory
not lengthy campaigns
thus it may be known that the leader of
armies is the arbiter of the people's
fate the man on whom it depends whether
the nation shall be in peace
or in peril
[Music]
of rewards dumou said
rewards are necessary in order to make
the soldiers see the advantage of
beating the enemy
thus
when you capture spoils from the enemy
they must be used as rewards
so that all your men may have a keen
desire to fight
each on his own account
[Music]
general colin powell has said
nobody in his right mind who has seen
war
who has seen death and war
can like war
or want war
colin powell also said
there should be no use of force unless
success is all but guaranteed
for should be used decisively
and its application should preferably be
short
as soon as the aims are achieved
american forces should be quickly
extracted
lest the military fall into a quagmire
[Music]
lionel giles noted
as for units of measurement there are
2.78 lee to the mile
and as for numbers of troops in early
chinese warfare as with the homeric
greeks the war chariot formed the
nucleus around which were grouped
certain numbers of foot soldiers in this
case
75 to each swift chariot
and 25 to each heavy chariot
[Music]
chapter three
attack by stratagem
basic strategies
not fighting at all
the five essentials for victory
census said
in the practical art of war
the best thing of all is to take the
enemy's country whole and intact
to shatter and destroy it
is not so
good so too
it is better to capture an army than to
destroy it
it is better to capture a whole regiment
an entire detachment
or a full company
than to destroy them
heads
to fight and conquer in all your battles
is not supreme excellence
supreme excellence
consists in breaking the enemy's
resistance
without fighting
thus
the highest form of leadership is to
thwart the enemy's plans
the next best is to prevent the junction
of the enemy's forces
the next in order is to attack the
enemy's army in the field
and the worst policy of all
is to besiege walled
cities the rule is
not to besiege wall cities if it can
possibly be avoided
for the preparation of defensive screens
movable shelters
and various implements of war will take
up three whole months
and the piling up of mounds over against
the walls will take three months more
the general
unable to control his irritation will
launch his men to the assault like
swarming ants
with the result that one-third of his
men are slain
while the town still remains untaken
such are the disastrous effects of a
siege
therefore
the skillful leader subdues the enemy's
troops without any fighting
he captures their cities without laying
siege to them
he overthrows their kingdom
without lengthy operations in the field
with his forces intact he disputes the
mastery of the empire
and without losing a man
his triumph is complete
and the weapon
not being blunted by use
remains sharp and perfect
this is the method of attacking by
stratagem
it is the rule in war
if our forces are tend to the enemies
one
surround him if our forces are five to
his one
attack him
if equally matched we can offer battle
if slightly inferior in numbers
we can avoid the enemy
if quite unequal to the enemy in every
way
we can flee from him
though an obstinate fight may be made by
a small force
in the end it must be captured by the
larger force
the general is the bulwark of the state
if the bulwark is strong at all points
the state will be strong
if the bulwark is defective
the state will be weak
there are three ways in which a
sovereign can bring misfortune upon his
general
and his army
one
by commanding the army to advance or to
retreat
being ignorant of the fact that it
cannot obey
this is called hobbling the army
two
by attempting to govern an army in the
same way as he administers a kingdom
being ignorant of the conditions that
obtained an army
this causes restlessness in the soldiers
minds
three
by employing the officers of his army
without discrimination
through ignorance of the military
principle of adaptation to circumstances
this shakes the confidence of the
soldiers
and when the army is restless and
distrustful
trouble is sure to come from the other
feudal princes
this is simply bringing anarchy into the
army
and flinging victory away
thus
we may know that there are five
essentials for victory
one
he will win who knows when to fight and
when not to fight
two
he will win who knows how to handle both
superior
and inferior forces
three he will win whose army is animated
by the same spirit throughout all its
ranks
four
he will win who
prepared himself
waits to take the enemy
unprepared
five
he will win who has military capacity
and has not interfered with by the
sovereign
victory lies in the knowledge of these
five points
hence the saying
if you know the enemy and know yourself
you do not fear the result of a hundred
battles
if you know yourself but not the enemy
for every victory gained you will suffer
a defeat
if you know neither the enemy nor
yourself
you will succumb in every battle
[Music]
[Music]
of advantage in numbers jung-yu said
if our forces are twice as numerous
divide our army into two
one to meet the enemy in front
and one to fall upon his rear
if he replies to the frontal attack
he may be crushed from behind
if to the rear word attack
he may be crushed in front
he further reminds us that
a small difference in numbers is often
more than counterbalanced by superior
energy and discipline
by applying the art of war it is
possible with a lesser force to defeat a
greater and vice versa
the secret lies in an eye for locality
and in not letting the right moment slip
[Music]
on the difference between governing the
state and the army he said
humanity and justice are the principles
on which to govern the state
but not an army
[Music]
opportunism and flexibility on the other
hand are military rather than civic
virtues
referring to the principle of
adaptability in employing officers demu
quoted
the skillful employer of men will employ
the wise man the brave man the covetous
man and the stupid man
for the wise man delights in
establishing his merit
the brave man likes to show his courage
in action
the covetous man is quick at seizing
advantages
and the stupid man has no fear of death
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chapter four
tactics
defensive
and offensive postures
winning with ease method and discipline
sunset said the good fighters of old
first put themselves beyond the
possibility of defeat
and then waited for an opportunity of
defeating the enemy
to secure ourselves against defeat lies
in our own hands
but the opportunity of defeating the
enemy is provided by the enemy himself
thus the good fighter is able to secure
himself against defeat but cannot make
certain of defeating the enemy
hence the saying
one may know how to conquer
without being able to do it
security against defeat implies
defensive tactics
ability to defeat the enemy means taking
the offensive
standing on the defensive indicates
insufficient strength
attacking indicates a super abundance of
strength
the general who is skilled in defense
hides in the most secret recesses of the
earth
he who is skilled in attack flashes
forth from the topmost heights of heaven
like a thunderbolt against which there
is not time to prepare
thus on the one hand we have ability to
protect ourselves on the other a victory
that is complete
to see victory only when it is within
sight of the common herd is not the
height of excellence
nor is it the height of excellence if
you fight and conquer and the whole
empire says well done
to lift a hair is no sign of great
strength
to see the sun and the moon is no sign
of sharp sight
to hear the noise of thunder is no sign
of a quick ear
what the ancients called a clever
fighter is one who not only wins
but excels in winning with ease
his victories bring him neither
reputation for wisdom nor credit for
courage
he wins his battle by making no mistakes
making no mistakes is what establishes
the certainty of victory for it means
conquering an enemy that is already
defeated
hence
the skillful fighter puts himself into a
position that makes defeat impossible
and does not miss the moment for
defeating the enemy
thus it is that in war the victorious
strategist only seeks battle after the
victory has been won
whereas he who was destined to defeat
fights and afterward looks for victory
the consummate leader cultivates the
force and strictly adheres to method and
discipline
thus it is in his power to control
success
in respect of military method we have
one
measurement
two
estimation of quantity
three
calculation
for
balancing of chances
five
victory
measurement owes its existence to earth
estimation of quantity to measurement
calculation to estimation of quantity
balancing of chances to calculation
and victory to balancing of chances
a victorious army opposed to a routed
one
is as a pound's weight placed in the
scale against a single grain
the on rush of a conquering force is
like the bursting of pent up waters into
a chasm a thousand fathoms deep
this is all there is to be said about
tactics
[Music]
said
true excellence is to plan secretly to
move surreptitiously
to foil the enemy's intentions and
thwart his schemes so that at last the
day may be won without shedding a drop
of blood
in as much as such victories are gained
over circumstances that have not yet
come to light
the world at large knows nothing of them
and the clever fighter
wins no reputation for wisdom
in as much as the hostile state submits
before there has been any bloodshed
he receives no credit for courage
jung yoo added
one who seeks to conquer by sheer
strength clever though he may be at
winning pitched battles
is also liable on occasion to be
vanquished
whereas he who can look into the future
and discern conditions that are not yet
manifest
will never make a blunder and therefore
invariably win
and salgoon remarked
the thing is to see the plant before it
has germinated
to foresee the event
before the action has begun
[Music]
lee chuan
told this story han shin when about to
attack a vastly superior army said to
his officers
gentlemen we are going to annihilate the
enemy and shall meet again at dinner
the officers hardly took his words
seriously and gave a very dubious ascent
but han shin had already worked out in
his mind the details of a clever
stratagem whereby as he foresaw it he
was able to capture the city and inflict
a crushing defeat on his adversary
referring to measurement and its
corollaries dumu concluded
the question of relative strength having
been settled we can bring the varied
resources of cunning into play
[Music]
[Applause]
chapter 5
energy and power
direct and indirect maneuvers
the power of decision combined energy
sunzer said
the control of a large force
is the same in principle as the control
of a few men
it is merely a question of dividing up
their numbers
fighting with a large army under your
command is in no way different from
fighting with a small one
it is merely a question of instituting
signs
and signals
to ensure that your whole host may
withstand the brunt of the enemy's
attack and remain unshaken
use both direct
and indirect maneuvers
that the impact of your army may be like
a grindstone dashed against an egg
this is affected by the science of weak
points and strong
the hollow
and the solid
in all fighting the direct method may be
used for joining battle
but indirect methods will be needed in
order to secure victory
indirect tactics
efficiently applied
are as inexhaustible as heaven and earth
unending as the flow of rivers and
streams
like the sun and the moon
they end but to begin anew
like the four seasons
they pass away
but to return once more
there are not more than five musical
notes
yet the combinations of these five give
rise to more melodies
than can ever be heard
there are not more than five primary
colors
yet in combination they produce more
hues
that can ever be seen
there are not more than five cardinal
tastes
sour
acrid
salt
sweet
bitter
yet combinations of them
yield more flavors than can ever be
tasted
in battle
there are not more than two methods of
attack the direct
and the indirect
yet these two in combination
give rise to an endless series of
maneuvers
the direct and the indirect
lead on to each other in turn
it is like moving in a circle
you never come to an end
who can exhaust the possibilities
of their combination
the onset of troops is like the rush of
a torrent that will even roll stones
along in its course
the power of decision
is like the well-timed swoop of a falcon
that enables it to strike and destroy
its victim
therefore the good fighter will be
terrible in his onset
and prompt in his decisions
energy
may be likened to the bending of a
crossbow
decision may be likened to the releasing
of the trigger
amid the turmoil and tumult of battle
there may be seeming disorder
and yet no real disorder at all
amid confusion and chaos your array may
be without head or tail
yet it will be proof against defeat
simulated disorder postulates
perfect discipline
simulated fear
postulates courage
simulated weakness postulates strength
hiding order beneath the cloak of
disorder is simply a question of
subdivision
concealing courage under a show of
timidity presupposes a fund of latent
energy
masking strength with weakness
is to be affected by tactical
dispositions
thus one who is skillful at keeping the
enemy on the move
maintains deceitful appearances
according to which the enemy will act
he sacrifices something that the enemy
may snatch at
by holding out baits
he keeps him on the march
then with the body of pick men
he lies and wait for him
the clever combatant looks to the effect
of combined energy
and does not require too much from
individuals
hence
his ability to pick out the right men
and to utilize combined
energy
when he utilizes combined energy
his fighting men become as it were
like rolling logs or stones
for it is the nature of a logo stone
to remain motionless on level ground
and to move when on a slope
it is also in the nature of a log or a
stone
if square
to come to a standstill
but if round shaped
to go rolling down
thus
the energy developed by good fighting
men
is as the momentum of a round stone
rolled down a mountain thousands of feet
in height
so much on the subject
of energy
[Music]
dumu reminds us of han shin's famous
reply to the first han emperor who once
said to him
how large an army do you think i could
lead
not more than one hundred thousand men
your majesty
and you asked the emperor
oh he answered the more the better
on direct and indirect it was said
in war to march straight ahead is jeng
turning movements on the other hand are
chi
emperor tai zhung said
a chi
indirect maneuver may be jing
direct if we make the enemy look upon it
as chang
then our real attack will be chi
and vice versa
the whole secret lies in confusing the
enemy so that he cannot fathom our real
intent
[Music]
lionel giles observes
there is emphasis on proper timing here
and restraint like that which keeps the
falcon from swooping on its quarry until
the right moment
there is also the matter of judging when
the right moment has arrived
referred to the falcons mode of attack
short and sharp
and said
this is how the psychological moment
should be seized in war
said
if you wish to feign confusion in order
to lure the enemy on you must first have
perfect discipline
if you wish to display timidity in order
to entrap the enemy you must first have
extreme courage
if you wish to parade your weakness in
order to make the enemy overconfident
you must have exceeding strength
jan yu related this anecdote of emperor
kauzu
wishing to crush this young noob
he sent out spies to report on their
condition
but the xiongnu forewarned carefully
concealed all their able-bodied men and
well-fed horses and only allowed infirm
soldiers and emaciated cattle to be seen
the result was that the spies one and
all recommended the emperor to deliver
his attack
liu jing alone opposed them saying when
two countries go to war they are
naturally inclined to make an
ostentatious display of their strength
yet our spies have seen nothing but old
age and infirmity this is surely some
ruse on the part of the enemy and it
would be unwise for us to attack
the emperor however disregarding this
advice
fell into the trap
and found himself surrounded
dumou pointed out the converse
if one's force happens to be superior to
the enemies
weakness may be simulated in order to
lure him on
but if inferior
he must be led to believe that we are
strong
in order that he may keep off
in fact
all the enemies movements should be
determined by the signs that we choose
to give him
dumu
relates this anecdote
leaders of the chi state were sent
against the general pang juan of way
sun pin said
our side has a reputation for cowardice
and therefore our adversary despises us
let us turn the circumstance to our
advantage
accordingly when the army had crossed
the border into way territory he gave
orders to show one hundred thousand
fires on the first night
fifty thousand on the next
and the night after only twenty thousand
pang juan pursued them hotly saying to
himself i knew these men were cowards
their numbers have already fallen away
by more than half in his retreat
sun pin came to a narrow defile which he
calculated that his pursuers would reach
after dark
here he had a tree stripped of its bark
and inscribed upon it the words
under this tree shall pang juan die
then as night began to fall he placed a
strong body of archers in ambush nearby
with orders to shoot the moment they saw
a light
later on pang juan arrived at the spot
and
noticing the tree
struck a light in order to read what was
written on it
his body was immediately riddled by a
volley of arrows and his whole army
thrown into confusion
on matters of combined energy dumou
stated
the general first of all considers the
power of his army in bulk
afterward he takes individual talent
into account and uses each man according
to his capabilities
he does not demand perfection from the
untalented
chapter six
weak points and strong
speed and distance
secrecy and concealment
the infinite variety of circumstances
sunsu said
whoever is first in the field and awaits
the coming of the enemy will be fresh
for the fight whoever is second in the
field and has to hasten to battle will
arrive exhausted
therefore the clever combatant imposes
his will on the enemy but does not allow
the enemy's will to be imposed on him
by holding out advantages to him
enticing him with a bait he can cause
the enemy to approach of his own accord
or by inflicting damage striking at some
important point which the enemy will
have to defend he can make it impossible
for the enemy to draw near
if the enemy is taking his ease he can
harass him
if the enemy is well supplied with food
he can starve him out if the enemy is
quietly encamped he can force him to
move
up here at points that the enemy must
hasten to defend
march swiftly to places where you are
not expected
an army may march great distances
without distress if it marches through
country where the enemy is not
you can be sure of succeeding in your
attacks if you only attack places that
are undefended
you can ensure the safety of your
defense if you only hold positions that
cannot be attacked
that general is skillful in attack whose
opponent does not know what to defend
and he is skillful in defense whose
opponent does not know what to attack
oh divine art of subtlety and secrecy
through you we learn to be invisible and
unheard and hence we can hold the
enemy's fate in our hands
you may advance and be absolutely
irresistible if you make for the enemy's
weak points
you may retire and be safe from pursuit
if your movements are more rapid than
those of the enemy
if we wish to fight the enemy can be
forced to an engagement even if he is
sheltered behind a high rampart in a
deep ditch
all we need to do is attack some other
place that he will be obliged to relieve
if we do not wish to fight even though
the battle lines are drawn
we can prevent the enemy from engaging
us
all we need to do is to throw something
odd and unaccountable in his way to
distract him
by discovering the enemy's dispositions
and remaining invisible ourselves
we can keep our forces concentrated
while the enemies must be divided
we can form a single united body while
the enemy must split up into fractions
hence
there will be a hole
pitted against separate parts of a whole
which means that we shall be many to the
enemy's few
and if we are able thus to attack an
inferior force with a superior one our
opponents will be in dire straits
the spot where we intend to fight must
not be made known
for then the enemy will have to prepare
against a possible attack at several
different points and his forces being
thus distributed in many directions the
numbers we shall have to face at any
given point will be proportionately few
for should the enemy strengthen his
front lines he will weaken his rear
should he strengthen his rear he will
weaken the front should he strengthen
his left he will weaken his right should
he strengthen his right he will weaken
his left
if he sends reinforcements everywhere
he will everywhere be weak
numerical weakness comes from having to
prepare against possible attacks
numerical strength
comes from compelling our adversary to
make these preparations against us
knowing the place in the time of the
coming battle
we may concentrate from the greatest
distances in order to fight
but if neither time nor place be known
then the left wing will be impotent to
sucker the right
the right equally impotent to sucker the
left the front lines unable to relieve
the rear or the rear to support the
front
how much more so if the farthest
portions of the army are a hundred li
apart and even the nearest are separated
by severally
though the soldiers of the enemy exceed
our own in number they shall not win
them victory
i say then that victory can be achieved
though the enemy be stronger in numbers
we may prevent him from fighting
schemes so as to discover his plans and
the likelihood of their success
rouse him and learn the principle of his
activity or inactivity
force him to reveal himself so as to
find out his vulnerable spots
carefully compare the opposing army with
your own so that you may know where
strength is super abundant and where it
is deficient
in making tactical dispositions the
highest pitch you can attain is to
conceal them
conceal your dispositions and you will
be safe from the prying of the subtlest
spies and from the machinations of the
wisest brains
how victory may be produced for them out
of the enemy's own tactics
that is what the multitude cannot
comprehend
all men can see the individual tactics
whereby i conquer
but none can see the strategy out of
which total victory is evolved
do not repeat the tactics which have
gained you one victory but let your
methods be regulated by the infinite
variety of circumstances
military tactics are like water
for water in its natural course runs
away from high places and hastens
downward so in war the way of the force
is to avoid what is strong and to strike
at what is weak
water shapes its course according to the
nature of the ground over which it flows
the soldier works out his victory in
relation to the foe whom he is facing
therefore
just as water retains no constant shape
so in warfare
there are no constant conditions
he who can modify his tactics in
relation to his opponent
and thereby succeed in winning
may be called a heaven-born captain
the five elements
water fire wood metal earth
are not always equally predominant
the four seasons make way for each other
in turn
there are short days and long
the moon has its periods of waning
and waxing
said
he who is skilled in attack flashes
forth from the topmost heights of heaven
making it impossible for the enemy to
guard against him
this being so
the places that he shall attack are
precisely those that the enemy cannot
defend
he who is skilled in defense
hides in the most secret recesses of the
earth making it impossible for the enemy
to estimate his whereabouts
this being so
the places that he shall hold are
precisely those that the enemy cannot
attack
if the enemy's dispositions are visible
we can make for him in one body
whereas our own dispositions being kept
secret the enemy will be obliged to
divide his forces in order to guard
against attack from every quarter
dumou said
if the enemy is the invading party we
can cut his line of communications and
occupy the roads by which he will have
to return
if we are the invaders we may direct our
attack against the sovereign himself
he also told this anecdote about
distracting the enemy
when occupying yang ping city and about
to be attacked by some of the first
suddenly dropped his flags stopped the
beating of the drums and flung open the
city gates showing only a few men
engaged in sweeping and sprinkling the
ground
this unexpected proceeding had the
intended effect
for samad the first suspecting an ambush
actually drew off his army and retreated
chapter 7
maneuvering
the art of handling large masses of men
sunder said
in war
the general receives his commands from
the sovereign
having collected an army and
concentrated his forces
he must blend and harmonize the
different elements thereof
before pitching his camp
after that comes tactical maneuvering
the difficulty of tactical maneuvering
consistent turning the devious into the
direct
and misfortune into gain
thus
to take a long and circuitous route
after enticing the enemy out of the way
and those starting after him
to contrive to reach the goal before him
shows knowledge of the artifice
of deviation
maneuvering with an army is advantageous
maneuvering with the non-disciplined
multitude
is most dangerous
if you set a fully equipped army to
march in order to snatch an advantage
the chances are that you will be too
late
on the other hand
to detach a flying column for the
purpose
involves the sacrifice of its baggage
and stores
thus
if you order your men to pack up their
equipment and make force monsters
without halting day or night
covering double the usual distance at a
stretch
and doing a hundredly in order to rest
an advantage
the leaders of your three divisions will
fall into the hands of the enemy
the stronger men will be in front the
jaded ones will fall behind
and on this plan only one tenth of your
army will reach its destination
if you march 50 lee in order to help
maneuver the enemy you will lose the
leader of your first division
and only half your force will reach the
goal
if you march 30 lee with the same
objective
two-thirds of your army will arrive
we may take it then that an army without
its baggage train is lost
without provisions
it is lost
without basis of supply
it is lost
we cannot enter into alliances until we
are acquainted with the designs of our
neighbors
we are not fit to lead an army on the
march
unless we are familiar with the face of
the country
its mountains and forests
its pitfalls and precipices
its marshes and swamps
we shall be unable to turn natural
advantages to account unless we make use
of local guides
in war
practice dissimulation
[Music]
and you will succeed
move
only if there is a real advantage to be
gained
whether to concentrate or to divide your
troops must be decided by circumstances
let your speed be that of the wind your
compactness that of the forest
raiding and plundering be like fire
in immovability
be like a mountain
let your plans be dark
and impenetrable as night
and when you move
fall like a thunderbolt
when you plunder a countryside let the
squirrel be divided among your men
when you capture new territory
cut it up into allotments for the
benefit of the soldiery
ponder
and deliberate before you make a move
he will conquer who has learned the
artifice of
deviation such is the art of maneuvering
the ancient book of army management says
on the field of battle
the spoken word does not carry far
enough
hence the institution of gongs and drums
nor can ordinary objects be seen clearly
enough
hence the institution of banners and
flags
cons and drums banners and flags these
are means whereby the ears and eyes of
the host may be focused on one
particular point
the host
thus forming a single united body
it is impossible either for the brave to
advance alone or for the cowardly to
retreat alone
this is the art of handling large masses
of men
in night fighting then
make much use of signal fires and drums
and in fighting by day
of flags and banners
as a means of influencing the ears and
eyes of your army
a whole army
may be robbed of its spirit
a commander-in-chief may be robbed of
his presence of mind
now
a soldier's spirit is keenest in the
morning
by noonday it has begun to flag
and in the evening his mind is meant
only on returning to camp
a clever general therefore
avoids an enemy when its spirit is keen
but attacks when it is sluggish and
inclined to return
this is the art of studying moods
disciplined and calm
to await the appearance of disorder and
hubbub among the enemy this is the art
of retaining self-position
to be near the goal while the enemy is
still far from it to wait at ease while
the enemy is toiling and struggling
to be well fed while the enemy is
famished
this is the art of conserving one's
strength
to refrain from intercepting an enemy
whose banners are in perfect order
to refrain from attacking an army drawn
up in calm and confident array
this is the art of studying
circumstances
it is a military axiom
not to advance uphill against the enemy
nor to oppose him when he comes downhill
do not pursue an enemy who simulates
flight
do not attack soldiers whose temper is
keen
do not swallow a bait offered by the
enemy
do not interfere with an army that is
returning home
when you surround an army leave an
outlet free
do not press a desperate foe
too hard such as the art of warfare
woods has said
without harmony in the state
no military expedition can be undertaken
without harmony in the army
no battle array can be formed
sunzer himself was quoted as saying
those who are waging war should get rid
of all domestic troubles before
proceeding to attack the external fight
dumu cited the famous march of ciao
to relieve the town of all you which was
closely besieged by a chin army
the king of chao first consulted liang
po on the advisability of attempting a
relief
but the latter thought the distance too
great
and the intervening country too rugged
and difficult
his majesty then turned to joshua who
fully admitted the hazardous nature of
the march
but finally said
we shall be like two rats fighting in a
hole and the pluckier one will win
so he left the capital with his army but
had only gone a distance of 30 li when
he stopped and began throwing up
entrenchments
for 28 days he continued strengthening
his fortifications and took care that
spies should carry the intelligence to
the enemy
the chin general was overjoyed to learn
of child's tardiness
but the spies had no sooner departed
than zhao began a forced march lasting
for two days in one night and arrived on
the scene of action with such
astonishing rapidity that he was able to
occupy a commanding position before the
enemy had got wind of his movements
don't march 100 lee to gain a tactical
advantage
maneuvers of this sort should be
confined to short distances
[Music]
stonewall jackson said
the hardships of forced marches are
often more painful than the dangers of
battle
lionel giles noted the following
regarding general jackson
it was only when he intended to surprise
her when a rapid retreat was imperative
that he sacrificed everything to speed
chen hao quoted the saying
birds
and beasts
when brought to bay will use their claws
and teeth
jung yoo said
if your adversary has burned his boats
and destroyed his cooking pots and is
ready to stake all on the issue of a
battle
he must not be pushed to extremities
who she told a story about this
a general was surrounded by a vastly
superior barbarian army
the country was bare and desert-like and
his little force was soon in dire
straits for want of water
the wells they bored ran dry and the men
were reduced to squeezing lumps of mud
and sucking out the moisture
their ranks thinned rapidly until at
last fuyen ching exclaimed we are
desperate men
far better to die for our country than
to go with fettered hands into captivity
a strong gale happened to be blowing
from the northeast and darkening the air
with dense clouds of sandy dust
an officer named elisho zheng saw an
opportunity and said
there are many and we are few but in the
midst of this sandstorm our numbers will
not be discernible victory will go to
the strenuous fighter and the wind will
be our best ally
accordingly fujian ching made a sudden
and holy unexpected onslaught with his
cavalry
routed the barbarians
and succeeded in breaking through to
safety
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chapter eight
the nine variations
advantage and disadvantage
the infinite variation of tactics
the five faults
[Music]
sunset said
in war the general receives his commands
from the sovereign collects his army and
concentrates his forces
when in difficult country do not encamp
in country where high roads intersect
join hands with your allies do not
linger in dangerously isolated positions
in hammed in situations you must resort
to stratagem in a desperate position
you must fight
there are roads which must not be
followed
armies which must not be attacked
towns which must not be besieged
positions which must not be contested
commands of the sovereign
which must not be obeyed
the general who thoroughly understands
the advantages that accompany variation
of tactics knows how to handle his
troops
the general who does not understand
these may be well acquainted with the
configuration of the country
yet he will not be able to turn his
knowledge to practical account
in the wise leaders plans considerations
of advantage and of disadvantage will be
blended together
if our expectation of advantage be
tempered in this way we may succeed in
accomplishing the essential part of our
schemes
if on the other hand in the midst of
difficulties we are always ready to
seize an advantage
we may extricate ourselves from
misfortune
reduce the hostile chiefs by inflicting
damage on them make trouble for them and
keep them constantly engaged
hold out specious allurements and make
them rush to any given point
the art of war teaches us to rely not on
the likelihood of the enemies not coming
but on our own readiness to receive him
not on the chance of his not attacking
but rather on the fact that we have made
our position
unassailable
there are five dangerous faults
which may affect a general
one
recklessness
which leads to destruction
two
cowardice which leads to capture
three a hasty temper which can be
provoked by insults
four
a delicacy of honor
which is sensitive to shame
five
over-solicited for his men
which exposes him to worry and trouble
these are the five besetting sins of a
general ruinous to the conduct of war
when an army is overthrown and its
leaders slain the cause will surely be
found among these five dangerous faults
let them be a subject
of meditation
[Music]
said
no town should be attacked which if
taken
cannot be held or if left alone
will not cause any trouble
sao goong told the story from his own
experience
when invading the territory of shujo
i ignored the city of hua
which lay directly in my path
and pressed on into the heart of the
country
this excellent strategy was rewarded by
the subsequent capture of no fewer than
14 important district cities
[Music]
replied
the city is small and well fortified
even if i succeed in taking it it will
be no great feat of arms
whereas if i fail i shall make myself a
laughingstock
[Music]
marshall terence said
it is a great mistake to waste men in
taking a town when the same expenditure
of soldiers will gain a province
of extenuating circumstances with
reference to the five obvious and
generally advantageous lines of action
if a certain road is short it must be
followed
if an army is isolated it must be
attacked
if a town is weak it must be
besieged if a position can be stormed it
must be attempted
if consistent with military operations
the sovereign's commands must be obeyed
but there are circumstances which
sometimes forbid a general to use these
advantages
for instance a certain road may be the
shortest way for him but if he knows
that it abounds in natural obstacles or
that the enemy has laid an ambush on it
he will not follow that road
a hostile force may be open to attack
but if he knows that it is hard pressed
and likely to fight with desperation
he will refrain from striking
and so on
he goes on to describe several ways of
reducing the hostile chiefs
entice away the enemy's best and wisest
men so that he may be left without
counsellors
introduced traitors into his country
that the government policy may be
rendered futile
foment intrigue and deceit and thus so
dissension between the ruler and his
ministers
by means of every artful contrivance
caused deterioration amongst his men and
waste of his treasure
corrupt his morals by insidious gifts
leading him into excess
disturb and unsettle his mind by
presenting him with lovely women
of the fault of over solicitude lionel
giles said
here's tsunza wish to emphasize the
danger of sacrificing any important
military advantage to the immediate
comfort of his men
this is a short-sighted policy
because in the long run the troops will
suffer more from the defeat or at best
the prolongation of the war which will
be the consequence
chapter 9
the army on the march
mountains
rivers marshes
planes
understanding the enemy
training soldiers
sunset said
we come now to the question of encamping
the army
and observing signs of the enemy
pass quickly over mountains
and keep in the neighborhood of valleys
camp in high places facing the sun
not on high hills but on knolls or
hillocks elevated above the surrounding
country
do not climb heights in order to fight
so much for mountain warfare
after crossing a river
you should get far away from it
when an invading force crosses a river
in its onward march
do not advance to meet it in midstream
it will be best to let half the army get
across
and then deliver your attack
you should not go to meet the invader
near a river he has to cross
moor your craft higher up than the enemy
and facing the sun
do not move upstream to meet the enemy
so much for river warfare
in crossing salt marshes
your sole concern should be to get over
them quickly without any delay
if forced to fight in a salt marsh you
should have water and grass near you
and get your back to a clump of trees
so much for operations and salt marshes
in dry level country
take up an easily accessible position
with rising ground to your right and on
your rear so that the danger may be in
front and safety lie behind
so much for campaigning in flat country
these
mountains rivers marshes and planes
are the four useful branches of military
knowledge
which enable the yellow emperor to
vanquish four sovereigns
all armies prefer high ground to low and
sunny places to dark
if you are careful for your men
and camp on hard ground the army will be
free from disease of every kind and this
will spell victory
when you come to a hill or a bank occupy
the sunny side the slope on your right
rear
thus you will act for the benefit of
your soldiers
and utilize the natural advantages of
the ground
when in consequence of heavy rains up
country
a river which you wish to fort is
swollen and flecked with foam
you must wait until it subsides
country in which there are precipitous
cliffs with torrents running between
deep natural hollows
confined places tangled thickets
quagmires and crevices
should be left with all possible speed
or else not approached
while we keep away from such places we
should get the enemy to approach them
while we face such places
we should let the enemy have them on his
rear
if in the neighborhood of your camp
there is any hilly country
ponds surrounded by aquatic grass
hollow basins filled with reeds or woods
with thick undergrowth
they must be carefully routed out and
searched for these are places where men
in ambush or insidious spas are likely
to be lurking
when the enemy is close at hand and
remains quiet
he is relying on the natural strength of
his position
when he keeps aloof and tries to provoke
a battle
he is anxious for the other side to
advance
if his place of encampment is easy of
access
he is offering you bait
movement among the trees of a forest
shows that the enemy is advancing
the appearance of unlikely objects in
the midst of thick grass
means that the enemy wants to make us
suspicious
the rising of birds into flight is the
sign of an ambush
startled beasts indicate that a sudden
attack is coming
when there is dust rising in a high
column
it is the sign of chariots advancing
when the dust is low
and spread over a wide area
hypertokens the approach of infantry
when it branches out in different
directions
it shows that parties have been sent to
collect firewood
a few clouds of dust moving to and fro
signify that an army isn't camping
humble words and increased preparations
are signs that the enemy is about to
advance
violent language
and driving forward as if to attack are
signs that he will retreat
when the light chariots come out first
and take up a position on the wings it
is a sign that the enemy is forming for
battle
peace proposals unaccompanied by a sworn
covenant
indicate a plot
where there is much running about and
the soldiers fall into rank
it means that the critical moment has
come
when some are seen advancing
and some retreating it is a lure
when the soldiers stand leaning on their
spears
they are faint from want of food
if those who are sent to draw water
begin by drinking themselves
the army is suffering from thirst
if the enemy sees an advantage to be
gained and makes no effort to secure it
the soldiers are exhausted
if birds gather on any spot it is
unoccupied
a useful way to tell that the enemy has
abandoned his camp
clamor by night betopen's nervousness
if there is disturbance in the camp
the general's authority is weak
if the banners and flags are shifted
about
sedition is afoot if the officers are
angry
it means that the men
are weary
when an army feeds its horses with grain
and kills its cattle for food
and when the men do not hang their
cooking pots over the campfires
showing that they will not return to
their tents
you may know that they are determined to
fight to the death
the sight of men whispering together in
small knots or speaking in subdued tones
points to disaffection among the rank
and file
two frequent rewards signify that the
enemy is at the end of his resources
too many punishments
betray a condition of dire distress
to begin by bluster
but afterward to take pride at the
enemy's numbers
shows a supreme lack of intelligence
when envoys are sent with compliments in
their mouths
it's a sign that the enemy wishes for a
truce
if the enemy's troops march up angrily
and remain facing ours for a long time
without either joining battle or taking
themselves off again the situation is
one that demands great vigilance and
circumspection
if our troops are no more in number than
the enemy
that is amply sufficient
it only means that no direct attack can
be made
what we can do is simply to concentrate
all our available strength keep a close
watch on the enemy
and obtain reinforcements
he who exercises no forethought but
makes light of his opponents
is sure to be captured by them
if soldiers are punished before they
have grown attached to you they will not
prove submissive and unless submissive
they will be practically useless
if
when the soldiers have become attached
to you punishments are not enforced
the soldiers will still be useless
therefore
soldiers must be treated in the first
instance
with humanity
but kept under control
by means of iron discipline
this is a certain road to victory
if in training soldiers commands are
habitually enforced
the army will be well disciplined
if not its discipline will be bad
if a general shows confidence in his men
but always insists on his orders being
obeyed
the game will be mutual
jumu said
do not linger among barren uplands but
keep close to supplies of water and
grass
chong yoo supported this idea with the
following story
my yuan was sent to exterminate the
robber captain
chiang
who had found a refuge in the hills
mayuan made no attempt to force a battle
but seized all the favorable positions
commanding supplies of water and forage
chiang was soon in such a desperate
plight for want of provisions that he
was forced to make a total surrender
he did not know the advantage of keeping
in the neighborhood of valleys
[Music]
lee chuan told of the great victory one
by han shin
over longzhu at the way river
the two armies were drawn up on opposite
sides of the river
in the night
han shin ordered his men to take some
ten thousand sacks filled with sand and
construct a dam a little higher up
then leading half his army across he
attacked mungju
after a time pretending to have failed
in his attempt he hastily withdrew to
the other bank
longju was much elated by this unlooked
for success
and exclaiming i felt sure that hanjin
was really a coward
he pursued him and began crossing the
river in his turn
hanshin now sent a party to cut open the
sandbags thus releasing a great volume
of water which swept down and prevented
the greater portion of lung juice army
from getting across
he then turned upon the force which had
been cut off
and
annihilated himself being among the
slain
the rest of the army on the further bank
also scattered
and fled in all directions
said high ground is not only more
agreeable but more convenient from a
military point of view
low ground is not only damp and
unhealthy
but also disadvantageous for fighting
zheng yu quoted liaoza
the art of giving orders is not to try
to rectify minor blunders and not to be
swayed by petty doubts
[Music]
[Music]
chapter 10
terrain
six kinds of ground
balancing the forces within the army
fame
[Music]
sunzer said
we may distinguish six kinds of terrain
accessible ground entangling ground
standstill ground
narrow passes
precipitous heights
and positions at a great distance from
the enemy
ground which can be freely traversed by
both sides is called accessible
with ground of this nature
be before the enemy in occupying the
raised and sunny spots and carefully
guard your line of supplies
then you will be able to fight with
advantage
ground which can be abandoned but is
hard to reoccupy is called entangling
from a position of this sort if the
enemy is unprepared you may sally forth
and defeat him but if the enemy is
prepared for your coming and you fail to
defeat him then return being impossible
disaster will ensue
when the position is such that neither
side will gain by making the first move
it is called standstill ground
each side finds it difficult to move and
the situation remains at a deadlock
in a position of this sort even though
the enemy should offer attractive bait
it will be advisable not to stir forth
but rather to retreat thus enticing the
enemy in his turn
then when part of his army has come out
we may deliver our attack with advantage
with regard to narrow passes
if you can occupy them first let them be
strongly garrisoned and await the advent
of the enemy
should the enemy forestall you in
occupying a pass do not go after him if
the pass is fully garrisoned
but only if it is weakly garrisoned
with regard to precipitous heights if
you arrive before your adversary occupy
the raised and sunny spots and there
wait for him to come up
if the enemy has occupied precipitous
heights before you do not follow him but
retreat and try to entice him away
if you are situated at a great distance
from the enemy
and the strength of the two armies is
equal
it is not easy to provoke a battle and
fighting will be to your disadvantage
these six are the principles connected
with earth
the general who has attained a
responsible post must be careful to
study them
an army may be exposed to six calamities
not arising from natural causes but from
faults for which the general is
responsible
these are flight insubordination
collapse
ruin
disorganization
and route
other conditions being equal
if one force is hurled against another
ten times its size the result will be
the flight of the former
when the common soldiers are too strong
and their officers too weak the result
is insubordination
when the officers are too strong
and the common soldiers too weak
the result is collapse
when the higher officers are angry and
insubordinate
and on meeting the enemy give battle on
their own account from a feeling of
resentment
before the commander-in-chief can tell
whether or not he is in a position to
fight
the result is ruin
when the general is weak and without
authority
when his orders are not clear and
distinct when there are no fixed duties
assigned to officers and men and the
ranks are formed in a slovenly haphazard
manner the result is utter
disorganization
when a general
unable to estimate the enemy's strength
allows an inferior force to engage a
larger one or hurls a weak detachment
against a powerful one and neglects to
place picked soldiers in the front rank
the result must be a route
these are six ways of courting defeat
which must be carefully noted by the
general who has attained a responsible
post
the natural formation of the country is
the soldier's best ally
but the power of estimating the
adversary of controlling the forces of
victory and of shrewdly calculating
difficulties dangers and distances
constitutes the test of a great general
he who knows these things
and in fighting puts his knowledge into
practice
will win his battles
he who knows them not
nor practices them will surely be
defeated
if fighting is sure to result in victory
then you must fight
even though the ruler forbid it
if fighting will not result in victory
then you must not fight
even at the ruler's bidding
the general who advances without
coveting fame
and retreats without fearing disgrace
whose only thought is to protect his
country and do good service for his
sovereign
is the jewel of the kingdom regard your
soldiers as your children
and they will follow you into the
deepest valleys
look on them as your own beloved sons
and they will stand by you even unto
death
if however you are indulgent
but unable to make your authority felt
kind-hearted but unable to enforce your
commands an incapable moreover of
quelling disorder
then your soldiers must be likened to
spoiled children
they are useless for any practical
purpose
if we know that our own men are in a
condition to attack but are unaware that
the enemy is not open to attack we have
gone only halfway toward victory
if we know that the enemy is open to
attack
but are unaware that our own men are not
in a condition to attack
we have gone only halfway toward victory
if we know that the enemy is open to
attack and also know that our men are in
a condition to attack
but are unaware that the nature of the
ground makes fighting impracticable
we have still gone only halfway toward
victory
the experienced soldier once in motion
is never bewildered
once he has broken camp he is never at a
loss
hence the saying
if you know the enemy and know yourself
your victory will not stand in doubt
if you know heaven
and no earth
you may make your victory complete
[Music]
zheng yu told the story about pei shin
who was sent on a punitive expedition
against the turkic tribes
at nightfall he pitched his camp as
usual
and it had already been completely
fortified by wall and ditch when
suddenly he gave orders that the army
should shift its quarters to a hill
nearby
this was highly displeasing to his
officers who protested loudly against
the extra fatigue which it would entail
on the men
pashing gian however paid no heed to the
remonstrances and had the camp moved as
quickly as possible
later that night a terrific storm came
on which flooded their former place of
encampment to the depth of over 12 feet
the recalcitrant officers were amazed at
the site and owned that they had been in
the wrong
how did you know what was going to
happen they asked
pashing jien replied
from this time forward be content to
obey orders without asking unnecessary
questions
[Music]
chen hao defined the six ways of
courting defeat as follows
neglect to estimate to the enemy's
strength want of authority
defective training
unjustifiable anger
non-observance of discipline
failure to use picked men
dumou told this story of the famous
general wu chi
he wore the same clothes and ate the
same food as the meanest of his soldiers
refused to have either a horse to ride
or a map to sleep on
carried his own surplus rations wrapped
in a parcel and shared every hardship
with his men
one of his soldiers was suffering from
an abscess and she himself sucked out
the virus
the soldier's mother hearing this began
wailing and lamenting
somebody asked her why are you crying
your son is only a common soldier and
yet the commander-in-chief himself has
sucked the poison from his sore
the woman replied many years ago lord wu
performed a similar service for my
husband
who never left him afterward and finally
met his death at the hands of the enemy
and now that he has done the same for my
son he too will fall fighting i know not
where
leech one tells similarly of the vi
count of chu
whose soldiers were suffering severely
from the cold
he made a round of the whole army
comforting and encouraging the men
and straightway they felt as if they
were clothed in garments lined with silk
dumoul
told the story of lumon during the
occupation of the town of jiang ling
he had given orders to his army not to
molest the inhabitants or take anything
from them by force
nevertheless a certain officer serving
under his banner
who happened to be from the same town as
the general
ventured to appropriate a bamboo hat
belonging to one of the people in order
to wear it over his regulation helmet
as protection against the rain
lumong considered the fact of his being
a native of the same town as the culprit
should not be allowed to palliate a
clear breach of discipline
and accordingly he ordered his summary
execution
the tears rolling down his face however
as he did so
this act of severity
filled the army with wholesome awe
and from that time forth even articles
dropped in the highway were not picked
up
chapter 11
the nine situations
nine strategic kinds of ground
advantages of adversity
changing plans
nine principles
alliances
and rewards
censors said
the art of war recognizes nine varieties
of ground
dispersive ground
fossil ground
contentious ground
open ground
ground of intersecting highways
serious ground
difficult ground
hemmed in ground
desperate ground
when a chieftain is fighting in his own
territory
it is dispersed of ground
so called because the soldiers
being near to their homes and anxious to
see their wives and children
are likely to seize the opportunity
afforded by a battle
and scatter in every direction
when he has penetrated into hostile
territory
but to no great distance
it is vassal ground
ground that can be of great advantage to
either side
is contentious ground
ground on which each side has liberty of
movement
is open ground
ground which forms the key to three
contiguous states
so that he who occupies it first as most
of the empires his command
is ground of intersecting highways
when an army has penetrated into the
heart of hostile country
leaving a number of fortified cities in
its rear
it is serious ground
mountain forests
rugged steeps marshes and fends
all country that is hard to traverse
this is difficult ground
ground which is reached through narrow
gorges
and from which we can only retire by
tortuous paths
so that a small number of the enemy
would suffice to crush a large body of
our own men
this is hemmed in ground
ground on which we can only be saved
from destruction by fighting without
delay
this is desperate ground
on dispersive ground therefore
fight not
on facile ground
halt nut
on contentious ground
attack not
on open ground do not try to block the
enemy's way
on ground of intersecting highways
join hands with your allies
on serious ground
gathering provisions from all sides
in difficult ground keep steadily on the
march
on hemmed in ground resort to stratagem
on desperate ground
fight
those who were called skillful leaders
of old
knew how to drive a wedge between the
enemies front and rear
[Music]
to prevent cooperation between his large
and small divisions
to hinder the good troops from rescuing
the bad
the officers from rallying their men
for the enemy's men were scattered
they prevented them from gathering
even when their forces were united
they managed to keep them in disorder
when it was to their advantage
they made a forward move
and otherwise
they stop still
if asked how to cope with the great host
of the enemy in orderly array and on the
point of marching to the attack
i should say begin by seizing something
that your opponent holds dear
then he will be amenable to your will
speed is the essence of war
take advantage of the enemy's
unreadiness
make your way by unexpected routes and
attack unguarded spots
the following other principles to be
observed by an invading force
the further you penetrate into a country
the greater will be the solidarity of
your troops
and thus the defenders will not prevail
against you
make foreign fertile country in order to
supply your army with food
carefully study the well-being of your
men
and do not over tax them
concentrate your energy
and hoard your strength
keep your army continually on the move
and devise unfathomable plans
throw your soldiers into positions
whence there is no escape
and they will prefer death to flight
if they will face death there is nothing
they may not achieve
officers and men alike will put forth
their utterable strength
soldiers in desperate straits lose the
sense of fear
if there is no place of refuge they will
stand firm
if they are in the heart of a hostile
country they will show a stubborn front
if there is no help for it
they will fight hard
thus
without waiting to be marshaled the
soldiers will be constantly on the alert
without waiting to be asked they will do
your will
without restrictions
they will be faithful
even without orders
they can be trusted
prohibit the studying of omens
and do away with superstitious doubts
then
until death itself comes
if our soldiers are not overburdened
with money it is not because they have a
distaste for riches
if their lives are not unduly long
it is not because they are disinclined
to longevity
the general must see to it that
temptations to shirk fighting and grow
rich
are not thrown in the way of his men
on the day they are ordered out to
battle
your soldiers may weep
those sitting up bedewing their garments
and those lying down letting the tears
run down their cheeks
but let them once be brought to bay
and they will display the courage
of a juan ju ort sao grey
the skillful tactician
may be likened to the shwaijan
now the shuijam
is a snake that is found in the chong
mountains
strike at its head
and you will be attacked
by its tail
strike at its tail and you will be
attacked by its head
strike at its middle
and you will be attacked by head and
tail both
ask different army can be made to
imitate this raijan
answer
yes
for the men of wool
and the men of the air
are enemies
yet if they are crossing a river in the
same boat and are caught by a storm
they will come to each other's
assistance
just as the left hand
helps the right
it is not enough to put one's trust in
the tethering of horses and the bearing
of chariot wheels in the ground
it is not enough to render flight
impossible by such mechanical means
you will not succeed
unless your men have tenacity
and unity of purpose
and above all
a spirit of sympathetic cooperation
this is the lesson
which can be learned from the schwa
the principle on which to manage an army
is to set up one standard of courage
that all must reach
how to make the best of both strong and
weak
is a question involving the proper use
of ground
thus the skillful general conducts his
army just as though he were leading a
single man by the hand
it is the business of a general to be
quiet and thus ensure secrecy
he must be upright and just
and thus maintain order
he must be able to mystify his offices
and men
by false reports and appearances
and thus keep them in total ignorance
by altering his arrangements and
changing his plans
the leader keeps the enemy without
definite knowledge
by shifting his camp and taking
circuitous routes
he prevents the enemy from anticipating
his purpose
at the critical moment
the leader of an army acts like one who
has climbed up a height
and then kicks away the ladder behind
him
he carries his men deep into hostile
territory before he shows his hand
he burns his boats and breaks his
cooking pots
like a shepherd driving a flock of sheep
he drives his men this way in that
and none knows whether he is going
it is the business of a general to
muster his host and bring it into danger
the different measures suited to the
nine varieties of ground the expediency
of aggressive or defensive tactics
and the fundamental laws of human nature
these are things that must most
certainly be studied
when invading hostile territory
the general principle is that
penetrating deeply
brings cohesion
penetrating but a short way
means dispersion
when you leave your own country behind
and take your army across neighboring
territory
you find yourself on critical ground
when there are means of communication on
all four sides
the ground is one of intersecting
highways
when you penetrate deeply into a country
it is serious
ground when you penetrate but a little
way
it is vassal ground
when you have the enemy strongholds on
your rear and narrow passes in front
it is hemmed in ground
when there is no place of refuge at all
it is desperate ground
therefore on dispersive ground i would
inspire my men with unity of purpose
on facile ground
i would see that there is close
connection between all parts of my army
on contentious ground i would hurry up
my rear guard
on open ground
i would keep a vigilant eye on my
defenses
on ground of intersecting highways
i would consolidate my alliances
on serious ground
i would try to ensure a continuous
stream of supplies
on difficult ground i would keep pushing
on along the road
on hemmed in ground
i would block any way of retreat
on desperate ground i would proclaim to
my soldiers the hopelessness of saving
their lives
for it is the soldier's disposition to
offer an obstinate resistance when
surrounded to fight hard when he cannot
help himself
and to obey promptly when he has fallen
into danger
we cannot enter into alliance with
neighboring princes
until we are acquainted with their
designs
we are not fit to lead an army on the
march unless we are familiar with the
face of the country
its mountains and forests its pitfalls
and precipices
its marshes and swamps
we shall be unable to turn natural
advantages to account unless we make use
of local guides
to be ignorant of any one of the
following principles does not befit a
wall-like prince
when a warlike prince attacks a powerful
state
his general ship shows itself in
preventing the concentration of the
enemy's forces
he over awes his opponents
and their allies are prevented from
joining against him
hence
he does not strive to ally himself with
all and sundry
nor does he foster the power of other
states
he carries out his own secret designs
keeping his antagonists in awe
thus
he is able to capture their cities and
overthrow their kingdoms
bestow rewards without regard to rule
issue orders without regard to previous
arrangements
and you will be able to handle the whole
army as though you had to do with but a
single man
confront your soldiers with the deed
itself
never let them know your design
when the outlook is bright bring it
before their eyes but tell them nothing
when the situation is gloomy
place your army in deadly peril and it
will survive
plunge it into desperate straits and it
will come through in safety
for it is precisely when a force has
fallen into harm's way
that it is capable of striking a blow
for victory
success and warfare is gained by
carefully accommodating ourselves to the
enemy's purpose
by persistently hanging on the enemy's
flank
we shall succeed in the long run in
killing the commander-in-chief
this is called the ability to accomplish
a thing
by sheer cunning
on the day that you take up your command
block the frontier passes
destroy all passports and permits
and stop the passage of all emissaries
either to or from the enemy's country
be stern in the council chamber so that
you may control the situation
if the enemy leaves a door open
you must rush in
forestall your opponent by seizing what
he holds dear
and subtly contrived to time his arrival
on the ground
walk in the path defined by rule
and accommodate yourself to the enemy
until you can fight a decisive battle
at first
exhibit the coinness of a maiden
so that the enemy will open his door
afterward
move with the speed of the hair
and it will be too late for the enemy to
oppose you
[Music]
chen hao said
to be on desperate ground is like
sitting in a leaking boat or crouching
in a burning house
[Music]
hoshi told the following anecdote about
speed
li jing was sent to reduce the rebel
xiao shin who had set up as emperor at
ching zhou fu it was autumn and the
yangtze being then in flood xiao xian
never dreamt that his adversary would
venture to come down through the gorges
and consequently made no preparations
but lee jing embarked his army without
loss of time and was just about to start
when the other generals implored him to
postpone his departure until the river
was in a less dangerous state for
navigation
li jing replied
to the soldier overwhelming speed is of
paramount importance and he must never
miss opportunities
now is the time to strike before xiao
xian even knows that we have got an army
together
if we seize the present moment when the
river is in flood we shall appear before
his capital with startling suddenness
like the thunder which is heard before
you have the time to stop your ears
against it
this is the great principle in war even
if he gets to know of our approach he
will have to levy his soldiers in such a
hurry that they will not be fit to
oppose us
thus the full fruits of victory will be
ours
all came about as he predicted
and xiao xian was obliged to surrender
nobly stipulating that his people should
be spared and he alone suffer the
penalty of death
shen told this story of general wang jin
who had invaded the chu state where a
universal draft was instituted to oppose
him
being doubtful of the temper of his
troops
declined all invitations to fight and
remain strictly on the defensive
in vain did the chu general try to force
a battle
day after day wang jen kept inside his
walls and would not come out but devoted
his whole time and energy to winning the
affection and confidence of his men
he took care that they should be well
fed sharing his own meals with them
provided facilities for bathing and
employed every method of judicious
indulgence to weld them into a loyal and
homogeneous body
after some time had elapsed he told
certain persons to find out how the men
were amusing themselves
the answer was that they were competing
with one another at lifting weights and
broad jumps
when wang jian heard that they were
engaged in these athletic pursuits
he knew that their spirits had been
strung up to the required pitch and that
they were now ready for fighting
by this time the chew army after
repeating their challenge again and
again had marched away eastward in
disgust
huang zhen immediately broke up his camp
and followed them and in the battle that
ensued they were routed with great
slaughter
said this of soldiers weeping
this is not because they are afraid
but because all have embraced the firm
resolution to do or die
were heroes known for personal valor
juan ju committed an assassination of
the cost of his own life
while sao gwaii
during a delicate treaty negotiation
held a knife against the chest of his
opponent until he was promised full
restitution of lands
do you said
burn your baggage throw away your
supplies choke up the wells destroy your
cooking stoves and make it plain to your
men that they cannot survive but must
fight to the death
said
the only chance of life
lies in giving up all hope of it
speaking of being deeply involved in a
perilous position told this story
when pancho arrived at shanshan
guang the king of the country received
him with great politeness and respect
but shortly afterward his behavior
underwent a sudden change and he became
remiss and negligent
spoke about this to his officers have
you not noticed he said that guan's
polite attentions are on the wing
this must signify that envoys have come
from the northern barbarians and that
consequently he is in a state of
indecision not knowing with which side
to throw in his lot
thereupon he called one of the natives
who had been assigned to his service and
set a trap for him saying
where are those envoys from the xiongnu
who arrived some days ago the man was so
taken aback that between surprise and
fear he presently blurted out the whole
truth
pancho
keeping his informant carefully under
lock and key then
summoned the gathering of his officers
36 and all
and began drinking with them
when the wine had mounted into their
heads a little he tried to rouse their
spirits still further by addressing them
thus
gentlemen here we are in the heart of an
isolated region anxious to achieve
riches and honor by some great exploit
now it happens that an ambassador from
the xiongnu arrived in this kingdom only
a few days ago and the result is that
the respectful courtesy extended toward
us by our royal host has disappeared
should this envoy prevail upon him to
seize our party and hand us over to the
xiongnu our bones will become food for
the wolves of the desert what are we to
do
with one accord the officers replied
standing as we do in peril of our lives
we will follow our commander through
life and death
this chain of reasoning
in attacking a powerful state if you can
divide her forces you will have a
superiority and strength
if you have a superiority and strength
you will over awe the enemy
if you over awe the enemy the
neighboring states will be frightened
if the neighboring states are frightened
the enemy's allies will be prevented
from joining her john you and jin lin
said
your arrangements should not be divulged
beforehand
there should be no fixity in your rules
and arrangements
chapter 12
attacked by fire and water
cultivating resources
census said
there are five ways of attacking with
fire
the first is to burn soldiers in their
camp
the second is to burn supplies
the third is to burn baggage trains the
fourth is to burn arsenals and magazines
the fifth is to hurl dropping fire among
the enemy
in order to carry out an attack with
fire we must have means available the
material for raising fire should always
be kept in readiness
there is a proper season for making
attacks with fire and special days for
starting a conflagration
the proper season is when the weather is
very dry the special days are those when
the moon is in the constellations of the
sieve the wall the wing or the crossbar
for these four are all days of rising
wind
in attacking with fire one should be
prepared to meet five possible
developments
one when fire breaks out inside the
enemy's camp respond at once with an
attack from without
two if there is an outbreak of fire but
the enemy soldiers remain quiet
bide your time and do not attack
three when the force of the flames has
reached its height
follow it up with an attack if that is
practicable
if not
stay where you are
four if it is possible to make an
assault with fire from without do not
wait for it to break out within but
deliver your attack at a favorable
moment
5. when you start a fire be to the
windward of it do not attack from the
leeward a wind that rises in the daytime
lasts long
but a night breeze soon falls
in every army the five developments
connected with fire must be known the
movements of the stars calculated and a
watch kept for the proper days
hence those who use fire as an aid to
the attack show intelligence
those who use water as an aid to the
attack
gain an accession of strength
by means of water an enemy may be
intercepted but not robbed of all his
belongings
unhappy is the fate of one who tries to
win his battles and succeed in his
attacks without cultivating the spirit
of enterprise for the result is waste of
time and general stagnation
hence the saying
the enlightened ruler lays his plans
well ahead
the good general cultivates his
resources
not unless you see an advantage
use not your troops unless there is
something to be gained
fight not unless the position is
critical
no ruler should put troops into the
field merely to satisfy his own rage
no general should fight a battle simply
out of anger
anger may in time change to gladness
fixation may be succeeded by content
but a kingdom that has once been
destroyed
can never come again into being
nor can the dead
ever be brought back to life
hence the enlightened ruler is heedful
and the good general full of caution
this is the way to keep a country at
peace
and an army intact
[Music]
dumou illustrated the principle of
attack by fire with these anecdotes
the famous li ling once baffled the
leader of the xiangnu
when the latter taking advantage of a
favorable wind tried to set fire to the
chinese general's camp only to find that
every scrap of combustible vegetation in
the neighborhood had already been burned
down
on the other hand poltzai
a general of the yellow turbine rebels
was badly defeated through his neglect
of this simple precaution
at the head of a large army he was
besieging a very small garrison held by
wang fu sung who called his officers
together and said
in war there are various indirect
methods of attack
and numbers do not count for everything
now the rebels have pitched their camp
in the midst of thick grass which will
easily burn when the wind blows
if we set fire to it at night they will
be thrown into a panic and we can make a
sortie and attack them on all sides at
once
that evening a strong breeze sprang up
so wang fu sung instructed his soldiers
to bind reeds together into torches and
mount guard on the city walls after
which he sent out a band of daring men
who stealthily made their way through
the lines and started the fire with loud
shouts and yells
simultaneously a glare of light shot up
from the city walls
and wangfu sung sounding his drums led a
rapid charge which threw the rebels into
confusion and put them to headlong
flight
dumou said
if the wind is in the east
begin burning to the east of the enemy
and follow up the attack yourself from
that side
if you start a fire on the east side and
then attack from the west you will
suffer in the same way as your enemy
regarding the enlightened ruler
dumoul said
the warlike prince controls his soldiers
by his authority
knits them together by good faith
and keeps them loyal by means of rewards
if faith decays
there will be disruption
if rewards are deficient
commands will not be respected
[Music]
chapter 13
the use of spies
divine manipulation of the threads
sunder said
raising a host of a hundred thousand men
and marching them great distances
entails heavy loss on the people and a
drain on the resources of the state
the daily expenditure will amount to a
thousand ounces of silver
there will be commotion at home and
abroad
and men will drop down exhausted on the
highways
as many as seven hundred thousand
families will be impeded in their labor
hostile armies may face each other for
years
striving for the victory that is decided
in a single day
this being so
to remain in ignorance of the enemy's
condition simply because one grudges the
outlay of 100 ounces of silver in honors
and fees is the height of inhumanity
one who acts thus is no leader of men
no help to a sovereign
and no master of victory
what enables the wise sovereign in the
good general to strike and conquer
achieving things beyond the reach of
ordinary men
is for knowledge
now this foreknowledge cannot be
elicited from spirits
it cannot be obtained inductively from
experience
nor by any deductive calculation
knowledge of the enemy's dispositions
can only be obtained from other men
hence
the use of spies
of whom there are five classes
local spies internal spies
converted spies
doomed spies
surviving spies
when these five kinds of spies are all
at work
none can discover the secret system
this is called
the divine manipulation of the threads
it is the sovereign's most precious
faculty
having local spies means employing the
services of the inhabitants of a
district
having internal spies
means making use of officials of the
enemy
having converted spies
means getting hold of the enemy's spies
and using them for our own purposes
having doomed spies means doing certain
things openly for purposes of deception
and allowing our own spies to know of
them and report them to the enemy
surviving spies finally
are those who bring back news from the
enemy's camp
hence it follows that there must be no
more intimate relations in the whole
army than those maintained with spies
no one should be more liberally rewarded
and nowhere else should greater secrecy
be preserved
spies cannot be usefully employed
without a certain intuitive sagacity
spies cannot be properly managed without
benevolence and directness
without subtle ingenuity of mind
one cannot make certain of the truth of
their reports
be
subtle be
subtle
and use your spies for every kind of
business
if a secret piece of news is divulged by
a spy before the time is ripe
he must be put to death together with
the person to whom the secret was told
whether the object be to crush an army
to storm a city or to assassinate an
individual
it is always necessary to begin by
finding out the names of the attendants
the aids to camp the doorkeepers and
centuries of the general in command
our spies must be commissioned to
ascertain these
the enemy spies who have come to spy on
us must be sought out
tempted with bribes led away and
comfortably housed
thus they will become converted spies
and available for our service
it is through the information brought by
the converted spy
that we are able to acquire and employ
local and internal spies
it is owing to his information again
that we can cause the doomed spy to
carry false tidings to the enemy
lastly
it is by his information that the
surviving spy can be used on appointed
occasions
the end and aim of spying in all its
five varieties
is knowledge of the enemy
and this knowledge can only be derived
in the first instance
from the converted spy
hence it is essential
that the converted spy be treated with
the utmost
liberality
of old
the rise of the yin dynasty
was due to each other
who had served on the shah
likewise the rise of the joe dynasty
was due to lu yah who had served under
the yin
hence
it is only the enlightened ruler and the
wise general who will use the highest
intelligence of the army for purposes of
spying
and thereby they achieve great results
spies are a most important element in
war
because upon them
depends an army's ability to move
knowledge of the spirit world is to be
obtained by divination
information and natural science may be
sought by inductive reasoning
the laws of the universe can be verified
by mathematical calculation
but the dispositions of the enemy
are ascertainable through spies
and spies alone
dumou said
in the enemy's country win people over
by kind treatment and use them as spies
enumerating those likely to serve as
internal spies he cited
worthy men who have been degraded from
office
criminals who have undergone punishment
favored concubines who are greedy for
gold
men who are grieved at being in
subordinate positions or who have been
passed over in the distribution of posts
others who are anxious that their side
should be defeated in order that they
may have a chance of displaying their
ability and talents
fickle turncoats who always want to have
a foot in each boat
officials of these kind should be
secretly approached and bound to one's
interest by means of rich presence
in this way you will be able to find out
the state of affairs in the enemy's
country ascertain the plans that are
being formed against you and
moreover disturb the harmony and create
a breach between the sovereign and his
ministers
but
there is a necessity for extreme caution
in dealing with internal spies
of converted spies john you said
we must tempt the converted spy into our
service because it is he who knows which
of the local inhabitants are greedy of
gain
and which of the officials are open to
corruption
of converted spies
do you said
by means of heavy bribes and liberal
promises detach them from the enemy's
service and induce them to carry back
false information as well as to spy in
turn on their own countrymen
and of doomed spies we do things
calculated to deceive our own spies who
must be led to believe that they have
been unwittingly disclosed
then when these spies are captured in
the enemy's lines they will make an
entirely false report and the enemy will
take measures accordingly only to find
that we do something quite different
the spies will thereupon be put to death
dumou further spoke of surviving spies
this is the ordinary class of spies who
should form a regular part of the army
your surviving spy must be a man of keen
intellect though an outward appearance
of fool
he must be of shabby exterior but with a
will of iron
he must be active
robust and endowed with physical
strength and courage
he must be thoroughly accustomed to all
sorts of dirty work able to endure
hunger and cold shame and ignominy
of the sagacity required by one who uses
spies dumou said
before using spies we must assure
ourselves as to their integrity of
character and the extent of their
experience and skill
a brazen face and a crafty disposition
are more dangerous than mountains or
rivers
it takes a man of genius to penetrate
such
dia lynn said
an army without spies
is like a man without ears or eyes
[Music]
fighting south of the castle
an anonymous chinese poem circa 124 bce
they fought south of the castle
they died north of the wall
they died in the moors
and were not buried
their flesh was the food of crows
tell the crows we are not afraid we have
died in the moors and cannot be buried
crows
how can our bodies escape you
the waters flow deep and the rushes in
the pool were dark
the riders fought and were slain
their horses wandered naying
by the bridge there was a house
was
itself was it north
the harvest was never gathered
how can we give you your offerings
you served your prince faithfully
though all in vain
i think of you faithful soldiers
your service shall not be forgotten
for in the morning you went out to
battle
and at night you did not return
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you